Travis Scott smells like he takes a
shower in the morning usually Amy smells
like fresh shower and fresh Cologne we
are learning a whole lot more about
Kylie Travis and baby stormy hit it wait
he also smells like weed a lot kylie is
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show again and
this time she's playing a round of
burning questions yep daughter stormy
plays - and it turns out she's a little
shady for a one-year-olds who lives you
the most Wow every time hilarious a
celeb I'd like to collab with is stormy
webster we've yet to collab with you
throughout the segment it's clear kylie
is a hands-on mama
but this mess stormy has made recently
she's really into eminence
she gets the times and she melts them in
my hands then you put it all over my
white couch hmm what's the funniest
thing dad has done when him and stormy
play together it's the most funny thing
ever they scream and they yell and makes
her fly all over the house they have so
much fun together but Travis is just as
hands-on Hey
I mean so precious to be honest though
we've always known stormy was a fun baby
I mean it's so much fun the family grows
and it's getting bigger all the time and
yeah it's really fun to see the babies
have babies
Kylie was also on hand to fulfill her
commitment of giving 1 million bucks
away earlier this week she gave 750
thousand to a group called nest of love
that is a total that Kylie just gave you
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and on Thursday she surprised a fan her
name's Ashley she's 22 she's been going
through a lot the makeup mogul took
Ashley to the Kylie cosmetics
headquarters where things got emotional
I kind of resonated with your story
because of how much you love your mom
and assess with my mom I dropped out
because I saw the nehe like I saw her
tears like I saw all of that so I
stopped something I just took my job
Kylie ended up giving Ashley school
$50,000 and then she gave Ashley and her
mom a hundred grand each to alleviate
some of their financial pressures that's
it for today for all the latest on
Kylie's store me and the rest of the
Kardashians make sure you stick with all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
you